you
exaggeration estándar si el sistema
electronically Stanzione Logano said de
la parola subito al Presidente sure
Michelle presidental consider OPA
prego al elahh Ferrara resonant Macedo
Madame la razón de Leite remembrance
Monsieur de le parlement si por moi
- oh no particular allocation Poland
from neck for the processional
mezzo-soprano
repair redan Blair and et most women is
for developing tourism our institutional
locality or service deposit repair Ratan
T donate asunder formation of a
transparency Tony la semaine de yellow
Pony por por su non-visual Novus Ordo
conclude a treaty avec la natural nachos
non-traumatic
in Menasha two dozen tell preserve a que
la nozzle open Rindell para la
commission repented on my shoulder the
planned action poured initiative 1807
estimated removal ville de nosotros a
repair a concrete illuminated and across
collaborative neutrality thematic a la
razón de me sinto ave po RT / / preach
the toe mr. Alford implemented cetera
creative Suton unanimity Setanta de Jero
non voces de la banda red snow esata
medical researcher gtaeid dog
Sakura man obeah woman on the moon
project report Devon Guzman a feat mø
deficient a pain on business FA ultra
satin desmo
Raziel medical on evidence a fetcher
reckon Sahara roosterteeth homology the
analogies that transition limited the
Vitara a t-table a tear agreed upon
social necessity demonium finocchiona
Trina
the most palpable killer Pendarvis is no
they don't be so hard on thermal the
phenols mode action-oriented crema on
accurate adelmo the setter ambition met
one person just transition fund before
all consideration from the sea reality
tada our curiosity director tulipe
European Parliament for the deep our
situational
exactly Mali ma'am on an OC said
importance I know you that were in the
strategy he respected us Wadi different
Zeta more such a solid amidst energetic
when I tell you that is a limo alia of
extra promise you J a stencil
proportions Anila back technical
multimatic transform me so this is
officially an opportunity pop with the
cross off with denervation I prefer the
LOB and Contino leader polynomial is no
mission that I thought is ready for the
mobilization or departmental pay up or
taunted top of the OSI not contribution
per to the set objective ladies and
gentlemen the next European budget will
be very complex it is a complex and a
difficult issue because of the budget
gap we know that it means that countries
will have to pay more and other
countries will have to receive more it
means that we have to try to develop a
process of negotiation between the
leaders with respect for the role of
different Parliament
based on the treaties and I think that
this debate and se open budget it's not
only an issue of percentage of the GDP
that only an issue or national
contribution and of course it is very
visible at the national level but it is
also an important question regarding the
content the priorities the substance
what do we want to do in the next years
what's the added value we would like to
develop in the next years and that's why
another important part will be the right
balance we have to find between the
classical European policies like
agriculture like cohesion on the one
hand and on the other hand the new poll
the new challenges we have to face like
migration like climate change like
innovation then I think it will be very
important to work with open leaders work
also with the Parliament with the
support of the Commission in order to
try to take steps in the next weeks in
the next month another important part
without the budget will be this
discussion regarding the conditionality
and for different countries it means
different since the conditionality for
some countries we speak about ruleflow
for other countries we speak about
migration or about social or fiscal
damping another topic important topic
regarding municipal budget will be the
flexibility I understand that many
countries are in favor of more
flexibility and we will see as possible
to try to make a compromise on these
different issues another important area
will appear natural knowledge assume the
most proper Libya Newton says on budget
DC new polymer concrete is a relief from
contamination important for certain
energy release model system is for
certain Sergio the moon is the only
idler digital pod in Sergio Romo
contribution is a plastic profit
original dota sugestion convulsive a
centennial more directly Anton de cosas
de tiempo sin theta Clemenceau Jose
Medina modicum presentation server per
capita Commission European the poufy
artisanal Act is not the consideration
militarily a visitor mama
the Atlantis on the policy the economy a
depressive
I tell my mom also conserve approach
zone that a researcher a teacher for
Latino patented le wherever in this is
your final or the Falcons repair the
sweetie
Indian more entrepreneurial development
repair America's you know this shows the
directly voltage available more American
portal you yes far away to the
delegation
[Music]
the ELMO so la da da da da cidade navajo
edited create a tremendous revenue
you deserve a cappella you see on primal
Sweden Antonio into operation at what
has it what average LaGrant a
traditional CJ economic commercial mercy
national security
the default nuevo negocio de Bourgh
delicacy on the second faranzano
featured an original tofurkey non said
to say on the commemoration for the
treaty the lisbon the dance physical
conservator co kzo co in new host on
también SE desperation the
the situation Daryl Daryl tan Moody's
departed concezione or different you so
deplorable poverty infertility tanto de
Centro predated spectator passive the
decision proportion zoton Doumbia set
appellant mobilization associate a civil
medicine situation determination of
probable no adelmo problem co-president
circulate not Roswell audible considered
invasive a problem o algo para mañana de
reportero para ella está el volcán
vanilla the doctor say capacity diction
aku Amalia term agenda strategic
[Music]
capacity even see a few extra more
importantly twelve new mobility oh now
see Lopez no
devotee relations international I can
focus practically earlier Evita
situation on Turkey on Italian debate
relax
swatted also console honor allocation
Lana portion with Deborah strata little
flaw jeopardy Internacional means Evo
graphically shows over personality Allah
dress with the development recent
Genesis legend DeMille van Rijn sweetie
Edelman presentations ago proposition
limited detriment proposition you see
descend a strategy for linear portion we
don't he'll attempt to New Zealand
debate Lane Emerson spoke luigi de
consejo de clima y la Vida mala and
pesantren eleven that political party no
reason or indeed Linda digital server OC
Anton important innovative work up canto
and some constantly principal more
hospital to the new Italian
a lamp led monte solaro to stay with the
predominant estimate Alan Antonio it
lasted
no vision labid data Lanta visions
artificial diplomacy Sanjay cirrhosis
Regina trammel Putin at a negative and a
positive
oh she Oded Peduto se da da da da Jandra
linear portion solitaire reportero para
de blasio adelmo
de Sol de sitio VT y de force some extra
memo a social and family and a capacity
for Bob the Paladin voir photo low blow
Internacional de Beauvoir novella not on
TV in the fairness of capacity a
positive Tony Rosa
Roberto normal person typically SATA
past appropriate factor an actor the
stability the possibility for molecule
personal Pominville multilateralism
you see an extremely more important the
on practically the whole look is not a
creeper romania strategy to conservator
important a national we will have next
year different important summits with
other countries in the world are the
regions in the world
first of all Africa Africa is in my
opinion a very important challenge of
for the future of Europe and I hope it
be possible in the next reason it's not
with different permission to develop a
good strategic partnership a good
preparation in order to to deliver
concrete results and another important
summit will have next year China we talk
about climate change it is one of the
important topics we have to discuss with
this important country and I think this
video that will also have the occasion
to world where we are in order to try to
be to be efficient and to try to to
deliver more in order to to try to to
get more results and to promote also our
common interest with Jordan we settled
our studies relationships with other
actors in the world when the Monsieur
concretely calculated to move over this
also see Muslim
de pardon vesicular institutions -
democracy destitution LT su a potato
exceptional Fernet word opportunity bola
de reportero para Newsom a purplish
wasn't a penetrated ohon op le pare
funded appeal immobilization Doha
Visionnaire L module
Francois Mitterrand you have a
circulation disability not regeneration
quality Centro present a no say
Parliament cell present
Oh Deborah Commission will consider not
Resnick on politics on david levy
because a repair Elliott wa mou nanimo
from president consider opera envision
2011 conference have a cotillion for
Silla conference organized institutions
like conference
Austin is institutions to the conference
actually popular conscious Monica
College a conference poor novella retain
the Robinsons the procedure
humans per citizen
assembly indirect with a special level
this perform M : the Paris Opera
columnar is a formula focused on on
please deposit or opera drama si grazie
Presidente Michelle Presidente from the
lion prego Layla berola
mr. president honourable men members let
me first congratulate President shall
Michelle on sharing his first council
it was quite an impressive start of the
mandate indeed one week ago we discussed
in the parliament European Green Deal
the day after I brought the same
proposal to the European Council and the
council has endorsed the goal to make
our continent climate neutral by 2050 we
have explained to the leaders the core
of our proposal and that is to transform
our continents growth strategy for too
long
global growth has been based on
predatory ideas humanity took away
resources from the environment and in
exchange produced waste and pollution
this has to change and I'm convinced
this can't change with the European
Green Deal
we aim as a growth model that gives back
to our planet more than it takes away
from it in fact I am convinced that
leadership on environmental protection
and a Sun a strong industrial base are
just two sides of the same coin
to support this kind of clean innovation
of course we will need a far-reaching
investment in education a far-reaching
investment in skills development but
this has this investment in education
and skills development has always been
at the core of our European social
market economy so I'm convinced that
this principle which I'd call
competitive sustainability must be out
principle for the future of the social
market economy in Europe honourable
members all member states have different
starting points and special problems to
tackle and I want to give you some
examples Poland indeed as President
Michel said will have to transform large
coal mining regions actually as does
eastern Germany so at the European
Council Poland has asked for more time
to have a closer look at our proposal
for the just transition fund I'm very
keen on working with the Member States
on this and we have already started
discussing how to suit
people and regions and companies that
indeed have a longer way to come other
member states have different issues
Portugal for example Portugal is one of
the countries most affected by climate
change
lots of coasts hurricanes floods
horrible forest fires have taken already
a very high toll last year sixty people
lost their lives in the fires Portugal
has started its clean transition already
in 2005 and has invested significantly
since then it will close its last coal
mine already in 2023 it already has a
surplus in renewable energies and
together with the Dutch government
Portugal is now working on green
hydrogen energy so the question for
Portugal is how to transform and
transport its renewable energy through
Spain through France to the other
countries that need this renewable
energy from the Portuguese perspective
the European Green Deal is about energy
infrastructure is about
interconnectivity and is about an
adaptation of to climate change third
example in Sweden steel companies are
working on carbon free steel production
it sounds cereal but its carbon free
steel production and they are confident
they can get there in a matter of a few
years but for that they need the
reassurance that they will not face
unfair competition from abroad they want
steel production to be sustainable for
the environment and they want to remain
competitive on the global steel market
and this is the essence of competitive
sustainability indeed many member states
during the council's were council were
asking for the carbon border mechanism
we're working on it
so that it can protect our businesses it
can protect the environment
respect WTO rules honorable members we
have started our work on the European
Green Deal five months ago in this very
same hemicycle in the coming weeks and
months we will flesh out our plan the
council has endorsed the European Green
Deal your resolution will give it even a
greater momentum the task ahead of us is
tremendous but if we will be together as
three institutions we will win that
battle that is a difficult one a huge
task and we've seen last week how much
power is behind us if the three
institutions work together Michelle
madam Jami Julie depicting knows
ambition of a pen on bonsoir doses
adequate put real easy Sinatra
description polo Portia do Jay Orbin
know convey note two scallop opposition
actually Tonkawa the set objective a
commission Suzie Andhra plenum Oh the
president agency of a pea son Michel
dance is a faux pas des Garcons ensues
équilibre a key table a embouchure a
vote Raghava Mariela president a Palomar
a peon debates are solely Davo defended
une voix first trade first a bj
appropriate pon de la unión de Caen say
merci beaucoup de retour sur le
necessary Arabic knows ambition is on
Cosmo Yolanda strategic do consul ileal
is orientation politic de la commission
leader proposition so far more
concurrent resolution over de resulta
allow a Tejanos DiNozzo mission ill no
further a sous chef isn't a celebrity a
property area consult solution in for
dis cutie the nouvelle versus proper
Paul in European MXC shuttle Michelle
Bachman surname up know it is limit
rating system ill grandi sat 80s set
idea supported in Susa
the vs. nouvelle prop coddled in
European man adamant hang up coordinator
of the Moya Watson get Harvey a very
international apologies are bogus for
the oil who is and recently she's
instrumented silver annotator opus in
the bed above your [ __ ] phones and I
want of yet understand Owens we have as
in under hunt we avoid [ __ ] binds of
available via poverty and hunger mines
are marked their always - tax that all
stocked in rehab that Suzanne abide
under Gemeinschaft about we muslin alpha
right scientists hook to rent for houses
from fewer I Nagar mines I'm available
to shovel the size of mine and that
suits again by the interior for me my
deck the capital marked only almost
fallen that real honeymoon for Island
incline on mid-level antenna Merson
Entebbe aloft in the mines unmarked sue
gong to capital home on dammit funded
grants beside Nevada from state taxation
provision daffa ham regarding the mines
are marked a bhakti bank Union was for
interference its most of Berkeley site
that's when uber London processor does
ina rights the National Bank
music-related see at Verdun when and
resides in Agra mines are iron logins
issue honk of cabal bird the bow hunt of
niched
of the necks the freezer - Martin um Dan
want a dog entity residence on
surveillance on workshops on yon chef
Estie me after my own give Isaiah polish
the end week-long test Okanagan big
budgetary instrument for convergence and
competitiveness long one it's much a hip
liquor for straighten the hot magma
isn't fine but he politician Anakin for
kids and rights for short visits that
instrument virtio by try to the oil
Cooper concluding far inland as what he
convergence averse talk to Vella
performance Ibiza
that surely Moses not met outside and
finance meeting under Lee
Macias not filled stash tbilisi owns
instrument on dr. by DT Commission and
sure the up courts on her skills
upgrading reinsurance element the center
table is Iran's mission is most their
filing by as roommate Russian external
shots this double is your own cash they
enjoy that sighs [ __ ] abide written
under name in Dec freezer should smooth
minor management research by Anna also
it physically comped won't Clyde site is
divided abating staffing finally
honorable members one word on brexit
with a clear victory of the conservatism
but Boris Johnson our assumption is now
indeed that the withdrawal agreement
will be ratified by the end of January
and by saying that if I look around in
this hemicycle and I look at our very
brave remain any peace I can only say
I'm sorry we will miss you
we will miss you thank you for your
courage thank you for having been at our
side
we'll never miss those who scream and
yell and now now thanks God without you
we are constructing our future
partnership to the UK our Newell
relationship should be as close as
possible for the sake of our businesses
for the sake of our students and of so
many Europeans to stretch their lives
across the channel this relationship
will be clearly different from today's
the UK will be a third country council
estás that's the Commission to lead the
next phase of negotiation and I want to
pay tribute to Michele Barney who has
earned everyone's trust through the
years
thank you very much Michelle for your
dedication a timetable ahead of us is
extremely challenging it will end by
December 2020 it leaves us very little
time in case we cannot conclude an
agreement by the end of 2020 we will
face again a cliff edge situation and
this would clearly harm our interests
but it will impact more the UK than us
as the European Union will continue
benefiting from its single market its
customs union and the 1770 hundred
international agreements we signed with
our partners but it is clearly not in
our interest we will organize these
negotiations to make the most out of the
short period on February 1st we will be
ready to propose a mandate for the
negotiations the United Kingdom indeed
will become a third country but at the
very end I hope for the sake of the
European people and the sake of the
British people that we will have an
unprecedented partnership this is not
the end
of something it is the beginning of new
relations between neighbors and I want
us to become good neighbors with our
friends in the United Kingdom
long live Europe grazie president from
the layin - la parola presenter weber